5.7 billion dollars is a lot of money
and while some proposed it go towards a
wall or gate thing we started wondering
what else can you buy with 5.7 billion
dollars well if you're feeling hungry
you could buy thirty four point two
billion strawberries or maybe you're
looking for something a little less
healthy like one point one four billion
Big Macs
of course the cost to fix Flint
Michigan's water pipes is estimated at
fifty five million dollars so they could
be fixed one hundred and three times
speaking of health we could fully
vaccinate 2.6 million children from
birth to age 18 which could have
prevented every death caused by
tuberculosis hepatitis B whooping cough
and measles combined in one year the
Avengers infinity wars could be made
seventeen point seven five times and
around seventy three percent of
Americans to get a fendt istana lip
paint come fall 1.2 billion around the
world could get a free pumpkin spice
latte 15 million Americans could have
their dental insurance covered for a
year or five hundred and forty three
thousand wouldn't even have to pay tax
while one hundred and forty two point
five million naloxone kits could be
purchased to help prevent opioid
overdoses feel like going green
two hundred thousand homes to be fitted
with solar panels which lasts up to 20
years or 84,000 people could get a Tesla
Model S change that to one of the
cheaper electric cars and two hundred
twenty eight thousand people could be
sporting a gas free vehicle what would
other countries think 5.7 billion is
more than three times belize's entire
GDP or you could buy more than 14 white
houses in America which is valued at 389
million a pop speaking of houses 5.7
billion could pay for every homeless
person in America's rent for nine months
we could pay off the student loans of
over 150,000 US graduates cover the cost
of more than a quarter of NASA's yearly
budget keep Wikipedia running for 228
years and make every science article
published in the US over the next four
years open access and available freely
to all that would be
cool of course most economists predict
that the wall will cost much more than
5.7 billion